[Music]
hi max guess our award-winning
independent filmmakers who broke
crowdfunding records with their
incredibly popular web series video game
high school about a school for elite
gamers here's a sneak peek at the
upcoming final season you want to come
say that to my face
who's asking the number one player in
that game you just suck that your Sergey
Brin juice but happen to your matrix you
used to be my hair you used to be the
best then blind game crew decent setup a
sense okay well that is not light faint
big blue pants sushi princess
[Applause]
guys thank you very much for being here
you've had phenomenal success with video
game high school and I would set this to
you backstage one of the things that and
I'll be honest with you and rages me a
little bit is you guys are so young and
you've been making these short films
you're special effects are 100 times
better than anything I've been able to
pull off in 21 years your stuff looks
great the special effects the stunts
effects with cars
oh we're clearly you're getting
professional stunt drivers that would be
used in a 100 million dollar two hundred
million dollar movie and you're getting
those kind of effects yeah well it's
kind of interesting because like we do
web stuff and everyone thinks Oh web
stuff it's just like cat videos and like
vloggers and something that that's not
you know it's also pornography say that
what do you do it's like a web videos
and it's like mmm it's like it's on
YouTube but this last season we actually
got to check off a bucket list stunt for
us we got to flip a car fully I don't
mean to assume that but I didn't think
you were driving it you to you you
flipped a car so you got money snot
involved so it's you'd be surprised
actually because like a car flip it's
like it's super dangerous but the guys
that do it like they make it look so
effortless like nothing is more
emasculating than watching stunt guys
prep for a car flip because it involves
like there's just five huge dudes
driving massive metal spikes into
asphalt as we were just tenderly asking
like where do we put the cameras I'd be
there saying where's the sunblock is it
in that trial be here and then I'll just
put this cream on there's an onset medic
and I would just ask for something yeah
so they set up a ramp and they say drive
it into the into the pavement and
another guys just straps into a car and
like they have to strap their hands to
the wheel because it's like well if your
hand goes out the window while it's
flipping you'll lose your hand right
okay we'll be over here way in the back
right and yeah we got to do a full-on
car flip I think I think we have that
let me show that where it words is
happening by the way what's the Griffith
Park where people just are Josh hikers
are jogging yeah tell everyone to stop
and then they came out like what happy
great if you didn't tell the joggers and
they were just and
Wow let's take a look
that never happens in real life Oh No
here's a new watch movies and cars are
spinning like that through the air
you're always aware that doesn't happen
in real life you know it's so specific
what's crazy is how they do it it's like
I'm like well when you're in the air
like how do you you know what do you do
that you just hang on and hope you land
okay that's it's like yeah you got a
helmet we were next to a cliff and
there's another truck or like what's
that truck for they're like well if it
starts going towards the cliff this
truck will just drive head-on and hit
the car to stop it from going off the
cliff
we're like is that I was like this is
the manliest thing we've done yeah our
tire go worry we have a truck that will
smash into him to keep him from falling
two feet
you